the number one reason i build massive  scale is i have zero interest in  convincing anyone i've shut down three  minutes into a business pitch if  someone's out they're out that energy  for me to try to get them in is not  interesting i'm even more conscious that  i don't want to be rude because i don't  want to think anybody that i'm big  timing you i'll sit through the meeting  but my brain shut off three minutes in  when i'm like they're out because i have  nothing in me and not because i've been  sick even when i was a kid trying to  sell wine i'd rather take that energy  and build leverage with someone else or  do the thing that will make them in  convincing is the worst game in the  world and it's the game the majority of  people in business play